what is a little thing someone can do  that automatically makes them a crazy  person bleed from the face  if you pick a scab off  if whenever you bleed on your face like  if you have a scab on your nose and it  starts bleeding you look crazy as [ __ ]  all right  because it happened to me in a meeting i  had a scab i didn't realize it was a  scab and we're in a general pitch  meeting and i was itching it and all of  a sudden someone's like  it's really scary they're like dude  you're bleeding and i was like huh  they're like no you're like legit  bleeding and it dripped on my shirt and  i was like oh [ __ ] and they're like dude  like okay he's bleeding what's going on  i'm on blood thinners because i you know  i take i take baby aspirin so and i'm  like oh and i couldn't get it to stop  and everyone's like do you need to go  home and i was like no i'm fine they're  like why are you bleeding and i was like  i have a thing  i think it's propecia